it's been two and a half months since
russia invaded ukraine talks haven't
produced much as russia steps up its
military campaign especially in the east
some neighboring countries now fear
possible russian aggression against them
and others are concerned about the
economic consequences of the war
nato's presence in lithuania has
increased to around 3 000 soldiers but
lithuania has joined other baltic states
in asking for more nato forces so is a
russian attack against other states
imminent and what will it take to
guarantee security in the region
while germany was planning to increase
its russian natural gas imports through
undersea pipelines lithuania had one
goal to break free and it succeeded in
fact lithuania was the first eu country
to cut completely from russian gas so
how did they prepare the nation to
survive without russian energy the
biggest supplier in europe will put that
to the lithuanian president itanas
nausieda talks to al jazeera
lithuanian president kitanas nasieda
thank you for talking to al jazeera
it's a pleasure for me
in the early morning of february 24 when
russia invaded ukraine what was your
first thought
it starts again
and probably was the first fought
because
just yesterday on
23rd we returned from ukraine
where they were with the president
angeli duda
visiting
vladimir zelinski
and you know you know this feeling of
war was already in the air
and so no surprise from your side there
was no surprise of course there would be
a small hope that maybe they will avoid
this worst
scenario
but probably it was too naive to expect
that this concentration
of russian military forces around
ukraine
is for nothing of course there was a
plan to just to implement this
terrible idea
to invade ukraine
and to try to occupy the whole country
who was the first person of nato you
called and what did you ask for
it's a very good question i think we
communicate communicated so much uh this
first week
uh with all the leaders and i think the
next day
we
visited brussels we met
on the european union level european
council
and i remember the speech of vladimir
zelensky on vgc
and you know his expression was like
this
uh colleagues maybe we talk
for the last time
maybe
everything might happen in my country
especially in the first days the feeling
was like this but also in your country
right you also my country is always on
the russian pressure and probably we we
used to live with such the situation and
you know we are well prepared
or with at least we try to prepare
ourselves for
any kind of aggression this is not the
only military aggression we are facing
or the threat we are facing
but energy blackmailing
economic pressure and all these last 20
years
we felt this pressure and we tried to do
our best in order to be ready to take
such challenges but the very first day
that russia invaded ukraine
did you think
he's coming for lithuania as well
i think if putin will be successful he
will come
after us and this is not only
the talk about lithuania this is
the next target might be
moldova romania
power baltic countries poland
of this empire is just without any
limits the deputy uh
foreign minister of poland told uh
talked to al jazeera in this show
earlier that he thinks that certainly
putin is aiming also for poland do you
really think that he also wants to aim
for lithuania yes i think i think this
is possible and only one
scenario we could avoid
putin's aggressions aggression against
our countries
is successful war successful for
ukrainian's war in ukraine
if stop putin will be
stopped there
yes it will be probably the end of
his
era and probably will mean some relief
for democratic countries in in europe as
a country was formerly part of the
soviet union
do you feel that people countries in
europe for example germany and other
countries
underestimated the risks of russia and
vladimir putin
i don't think that the world
underestimated his correct one
i think
it was of
just the feeling that
putin is better than we
expect
and there was illusion that we have to
do business with kremlin's regime no
matter what is going on
and only this war in ukraine
opened the eyes opened the eyes entirely
and i think it was a game-changer
changer in this regard and now i do not
see any leader in european union maybe
except one or two
who still thinks that
for the war in ukraine
ukraine is responsible or both countries
are responsible i think
every country in european union
understands the true nature of this
regime
and
the content of this
regime is just to be aggressive and to
try to swallow neighboring countries but
was it a mistake of the countries in
europe who had a different approach and
were engaging with with vladimir putin
and russia for a long time and what have
been the consequences if you would call
it a mistake
you know
i don't know whether
illusions are mistakes sometimes we want
to have some illusions yes
as a persons as the countries as a
politicians
fortunately it was not the case in my
country
nobody has any illusions about true
intentions of kremlin's regime
so this is the reason why we did our
homework we try to prepare for possible
such scenarios like we are witnessing
now
and this was the reason why we were
first
to say
we are ready to cut off all the energy
ties with russia
it's surprised because lithium 30 years
ago was probably most reliant on on
russian energy resources
we
implemented and we created all necessary
infrastructure just one day to say
nothing
this is the end and we will not
just finance
from our pocket
the uh war in ukraine
this is our moral duty and we are ready
to
to
fulfill it but a quarter of your gas was
coming from russia right i think two
billion uh tons a year you need and a
quarter came from russia
how are you now
making the gas demand we can cover
all our demand
through the clip of the lng terminal
it was established in 2014
we can satisfy our needs for crude oil
through booting s terminal it was built
in 1999
so 23 years
ago and the largest oil refinery in
lithuania
in majescay
belongs to pick an orland polish company
and this company said
even before the war that
they will not buy rational anymore
although it created some technological
problems problems for this company
because they need so-called oral type of
oil
but they were ready to solve this but
where is your gas now coming from
because you will want to guess this is
coming from
norway from united states and we created
all necessary infrastructure deep into
our ports
to accommodate
the
ships from qatar
so we have the agreement with qatar gas
and the qatar
gas will be provided to
our lng terminal too and plans to buy
gas from iran for example
so far there are no discussions about
the gas from iran but we first of all we
would like to buy
the
gas from
the countries
who has which have certain principles
values we
share
you were in borodyanka in ukraine on
april 14 just after a lot of destruction
happened there a lot of people died
you compared the situation to it's worse
than the nazis it was quite a statement
uh of course because during the world
war two around 60 million people died
why did you say that
you know we
are able to see these pictures coming
and some one thing is to see the picture
another thing is just to experience it
and it was terrible
finding
how
cruel are these atrocities committed by
russian regime there
to see destroyed
houses
to see
the parts of people in the streets
and you know this is this is this
experience was just shocking and of
course
my statement
was very natural because i just said
what i thought
you would still say it like that yes
absolutely i
think that
those atrocities are
terrible
not imaginable in 21st century and those
war crimes are not committing themselves
they are not fulfilling themselves
because somebody is responsible for for
this
regime people institutions
and even this
idea of just to restore the
former soviet empire
this is probably
the very beginning of those atrocities
because the people cannot understand
that every country every nation in
europe and not only europe in the world
has the right
to determine or to to to to to
create
its
fate and to choose the way they want to
go
talking about restoring the soviet union
we're now two and a half months into the
war are you now less concerned that
there might be an invasion from russia
into lithuania than two and a half
months ago
or can we say that looking at how the
war is developing that the pace of the
russian invasion is not as we might have
thought
the formula is very simple if putin will
succeed in ukraine
nobody can feel safe and the targets
might be very different and the targets
might be even
few of them at the same time not only
one country one target but many targets
if he will be stopped there
probably it will be end of this fear
and as i mentioned it is very important
for the stability of the whole region
one of the weakest points of nato is
considered to be in your country this
well key gap it's
the
gap a piece of land between the
russian exclave kaliningrad and belarus
which is backed by russia there have
been suggestions on state tv in russia
that russian troops should occupy that
piece of land which would basically mean
that the baltic states are cut off from
nato how worried are you about that
piece of land at the moment yes we feel
like the you know we feel sandwiched
between
a heavily militarized kaliningrad region
we see a lot of russian troops there we
see military equipment even tactical uh
nuclear weapons are there
you you sh yes we i think already
several years
russians brought their
nuclear attack tactical weapons
which is right next door to lithuania
yes uh not only lithuania but i would
say a baltic region too
and on the other hand we see belarus
which has a country
independent country that does not exist
anymore
after the elections in 2020
just lukashenko and
his government less left
or
just
do not have any signs of independence
and they are just but the province of
russian federation so what does it mean
militarily it means that
russian military forces
can use
russian soil
as a platfor to attack neighboring
countries what they are actually doing
right now from the
belarus
so the same is also applicable for
lithuania poland and other countries of
the region so we do not have any time to
react
because
military calculation changed
dramatically and this is the reason why
we are saying look the situation changed
very
evidently and we have to react
instead of talking all the time about
deterrence we have to talk about forward
defense in this part of eastern flank of
nato well for the deterrence you only
had like a couple of thousands of nato
troops in lithuania until now that's of
course not going to be enough right if
there's an invasion it's basically only
meant to slow down any any attack
what do you need from nato to protect
your country and to protect the baltics
we need more uh troops as you rightly
mentioned those several thousand
soldiers are not enough because the
russian capacities outpace our
capacities by several times
we need also military equipment and i
would say the kind of equipment which
allows us to switch
from the air polishing regime
to air defense regime
and of course this is very ambitious
task to create here defense systems here
in the baltic regions the region and
this is probably one of the priorities
at least i believe that this is one of
the priorities of the of the nato as an
organization
and they hope very much that we will
bring forward this agenda
and this topic uh in the coming
nato summit taking place in madrid in
june can you be more specific how many
troops are you asking for and what kind
of military equipment we are talking and
this is not only our discussion internal
discussion but this is also discussion
on the nato level
to turn
battle groups into brigade
so for lithium at me it would mean the
brigade
uh would you ask me if you would ask me
about our possibility to accommodate
these troops
yes we are working on it and we
ordered thousands of troops here right
much higher number of troops but we
already building the necessary camps we
also have the special
law on
new training area in rudinink which is
by the way closely to the suvalke gap
and all these infrastructure elements
are needed in order to be ready to
accommodate a much larger amount of
military equipment and to have
additional military
troops here in lithuania
this is their responsibility first of
all
by
germany because this country is leading
efp presence here in lithuania
but we are talking with american troops
too because our strongest ally within
nato
is united states as you as you know
united states have also some military
troops here but there was always a
reason why there were not many nato
troops here in the baltics in lithuania
because it was always a very sensitive
balance between deterrence and not
posing a threat to russia because russia
feels nato is coming too close to its
borders vladimir putin has said it
many times
isn't this increasing the risk if you
have more nato troops here on your
territory
would that not increase your risk
instead of decreasing
yes russians are using this rhetoric in
order to scare us and to probably to
intimidate just in order to
stop
increasing military equipment here in
the eastern region
eastern flank of nato
but i
don't think we should follow this kind
of of manipulation and this information
because as i mentioned
military troops or military equipment in
kaliningrad
outpaces our
capabilities
by several times
so before the war in ukraine
there was a consideration and maybe it
was correct that it is possible to
reinforce in cage in case of emergency
in case of possible military
intervention we can bring additional
forces and which will be able to defend
together with our national forces
our territory but
having in mind those strategic changes
as i described in belarus in in
kaliningrad i think we don't have uh
time
to reinforce and this is a reason why we
are asking for
boots on the ground but it's against the
founding act between russia and nato
from 1997 which said that there
shouldn't be too many nato forces close
to the russian border and also not too
close
are you not
violating this founding act we are not
violating this because as a this is a
responsive responsibility of both sides
and
one country does does not have any right
to increase the capabilities
to to intimidate and to attack uh
neighboring countries
and to require and to ask the other side
to do nothing or to just to passively uh
watch what is happening
i think
we should understand that
ambitions to restore the empire are
still there
ukrainians are
fighting
very hard fighting
with this kind of ambitions
they are doing very well they are
fighting heroic fight battle
with this big country called russia
and i think
the fate of ukraine and the fate of
europe will be solved there in the
battlefields in ukraine
i don't know if you heard but vladimir
putin told this story about a trapped
rat
that he was
he had this experience in his youth when
he was cornering a rat and the rat
attacked him basically he is using this
analogy of course to show that you know
russia could be feeling like that
feeling trapped
are you worried that it could escalate
or that even nuclear weapons could be
used
yes we cannot ignore
or
exclude any possibilities
i i still believe that maybe there is
some sort of
rational thinking if you would allow me
to express it like this way although i
see that what is happening now is is
just very difficult to explain by
uh irrationally
so there's no evidence they are there is
no one practical example which shows
that nato is our
organization is aggressive
and we have a lot of evidence that
russia is doing this
just starting for
from divorce in chechnya
first then the second
then
georgia
2008 then crimea
and donetsk lucan's
frozen conflicts in 2014
transnistria in moldova we have a lot of
practical evidence which shows that you
cannot believe you cannot trust
this regime because that even confirms
my question about the threat that it
could escalate into an even bigger war
and even a nuclear
war uh but you know if we will do
nothing
it will be direct invitation for putin
to proceed
finally i want to ask you because you've
been asking about a no-fly zone from
nato you have also asked germany
directly to send leopard tanks to
ukraine none of it has happened how much
support do you feel from nato in case
you are your country is going to be in
trouble if you already see the divisions
within nato also within the eu if you
look at the gas
germany is still buying gas from uh from
russia we wouldn't be so pessimistic
it's not a united front against russia
are you are you frustrated or
disappointed i'm not frustrated i
understand that we have 20 27 countries
of european union on the table
and they have not only different
opinions but they have different
situation
and i am really
optimistic because i
can follow these changes of attitude
changes of opinion
because i can witness that some of my
colleagues three four years not three
four years but three four months ago
we are talking about possible engagement
of russia into different fields now i do
not see that when i hear any talks about
engagement of russia anymore that's
another many of them
diplomacy there will no
diplomacy you know
i as i mentioned the fate of ukraine
will be solved not in the cabinets it
will be solved in the battlefields
unfortunately unfortunately this is the
case
but looking
at my partners in european union i i
should say that
the big revolution in minds already
happened
we
have woken uh up and i think this is
most important
looking forward president guitarist
from lithuania thank you very much
thank you very much
[Music]
you